[Musique]
nous avons ouvert ses actualités sur une
page où régne et l'amitié
je crois qu'on peut le dire après le
président de la république alors cela me
permet de vous souhaiter un bon soir
détendu mais tout de suite
il nous faut venir aux points chauds de
l'actualité aujourd'hui république
dominicaine vous avez vu est suivi notre
titre nous verrons les images tout à
l'heure et sud vietnam sud vietnam ou la
campagne anti française de ces dernières
semaines prend maintenant un tour
nouveau
tandis que débarquent 12/100
parachutistes américains qui viennent
renforcer les défenses de deux grandes
bases les bases aériennes de biennois et
de bulletins
tandis que les actions viet congs de
l'avis même des américains se
multiplient et deviennent de plus en
plus nombreuses chaque semaine le
gouvernement sigonney prend donc des
mesures anti françaises il décide de
suspendre les émissions culturelles en
français diffusé jusqu'à présent chaque
soir par radio saigon il expulse du sud
vietnam
notre confrère jean à georges le
correspondant de l'agencé france presse
à saigon et en outre le gouvernement de
saigon donne aussi l'ordre de détruire
les seuls vestiges de l'ancien monument
aux morts franco vietnamien monument
pour les deux guerres et pour la guerre
d'indochine
c'est à dire deux dragons de bronze et
des marches de marbre qui se trouvait au
pied d'une colonne déjà profané l'été
dernier au cours de manifestations
d'étudiants
notons le au passe pas
[Musique]